well former senior FBI profiler Mary
Ellen O'Toole spent her career studying
the criminal mind she's a director of
the forensic science program at George
Mason University thank you so much for
joining us good morning to you this
really is a race until the next bomb
what kind of profile would you start
building right now to find a culprit I
would be looking at the forensic and
results and also the behavior it's a
combination of the two so for example
the FBI lab will be looking at the
functionality of these devices are they
intentionally not working or are they
not exploding because of some problem
and if that's the case if they are
intentionally designed not to explode
but to create fear and panic then we can
possibly expect to see an escalation if
there's another batch of bombs that come
out this suggests to me that this is
someone that really planned this out
quite well so we should not assume that
mistakes that we see in the posting of
the packages are a mistake but maybe
done purposefully there's also an
arrogance about the about these bombings
this is someone who is creating a great
deal of fear and panic in New York and
in the DC area
and he's enjoying that my sense is that
the sense of power and control and
omnipotence that he's getting out of
really being the center of attention now
throughout the country is is probably
like a narcotic for him
so that can play a part in how these
bombs may start to evolve or how this
this series of attacks may start to
evolve
Maryellen I noticed you keep using the
pronoun here you convinced that it's a
man well I say he because anecdotally
when we've seen serial bombers they are
male but if the investigation points to
a female they won't disregard that
because of the gender I'm aware of the
case up in Erie Pennsylvania where the
pizza delivery man was killed when he
had a bomb around his neck the bomb
maker was a male but the ringleader was
actually a female but anecdotally when
we see serial bombers we tend to see
how could the packaging what could the
packaging what kind of clues could have
given investigators it seems that they
have a lot of evidence to work with in
this case you think so I do think so and
I think with a device like this plus the
packaging there's the potential for DNA
and fingerprints and trace evidence and
what I think is important and most
violent offenders don't realize this but
the DNA technology anymore is pretty
amazing and so even if the devices go
off they explode investigators and
analysts are still able to retrieve
possibly DNA fingerprints from particles
that that are exploded so when someone
is making a device they turn the wires a
certain way they may put a piece of the
device in their mouth while they're
working with their hands and then that
piece comes out of their mouth we've got
DNA so people are not that sophisticated
to what what can be used to obtain their
identity there is a wealth of
information here and this offender has
taken a lot of risks
yeah actually can't go back and change
that now yeah I think he will be found
Mary Ellen O'Toole thank you so much
you're welcome